Happy Star Wars Friday, everybody.
So we've got some really cool Kylo Ren / Rey stuff to break down
and I'll explain a couple really important dates.
We got new Jedi costumes,
We've got to talk about Rey's parents
Daisy Ridley said some really pointed stuff that erased a whole bunch of theories
that actually gives her a couple things in common with the Snoke character
at least with the way that they were created.
Star Wars Day, which is coming up next week, new footage stuff dropping
and then Episode IX Carrie Fisher and Rian Johnson returning stuff.
So let's start with the costume stuff,
but there is a new round of the Star Wars giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
It's just for a copy of the Rogue One Blu-Ray.
So if you ever wanted a reason to buy Star Wars video games,
it would be to get a peek at what's coming up in the new films
because the Battlefront II Star Wars stuff revealed what Rey's Jedi costume
and Kylo Ren's new costume is going to look like.
And I know there was a bunch of people talking about Kylo Ren's scargate stuff
I'll address that, but it's not that big a deal.
There was a funny answer that Rian Johnson had,
he made a big change to the way Kylo Ren's scar looks on his face.
So if you remember, back during Force Awakens, in their fight,
Daisy Ridley slashed him, and he had this big cut going down the bridge of his nose.
So when we got to The Last Jedi trailer,
a lot of people were like, 'hey wait a minute, why does Kylo Ren's scar look so different?'
and he probably could have healed that in a Bacta tank
So there's just a number of questions that people had about the look of his face,
in addition to his new costume.
So the answer is that Rian Johnson said that when they were filming,
the scar going down the bridge of his nose just looked stupid.
So, "I wanted to change it because it looked weird," which I think is a fine reason
But you can see the costume, both his and Rey's, just have a lot more color.
Rey is slowly moving toward the Jedi brown
which makes you wonder if she's on the Luke Skywalker path
from going to relatively colorless costume in the first movie,
to Jedi brown in the second movie,
and then winding up where Luke Skywalker ended up in Return of the Jedi, with like a full black costume.
You go the whole gamut.
And I know they're implying that there's a lot of darkness in The Last Jedi,
just because of all the red color in the trailer,
and the way they did the poster,
and there's even a crazy new rumor that Luke Skywalker has been keeping Darth Vader's kyber crystal,
the red crystal, hanging around his neck, and Kylo Ren really wants it.
So before I address that big rumor, just let me know what you think about their new costumes.
It just seems like Kylo Ren is going to be spending a lot more time without his mask on,
because most of the pictures we've seen him in, relative to Episode IIX, show him without it,
and it's even smashed in the trailer,
so either it was destroyed after his fight with Rey, or he destroyed it himself in his own rage.
Because it does seem like he breaks a lot of his own stuff. You just see him destroying consoles left and right
But obviously he's dressed a lot more like Anakin Skywalker was from Revenge of the Sith.
So I love how even though he's moving away from Darth Vader because he's not wearing that mask anymore,
he is still very much trying to emulate the path of Anakin Skywalker.
George Lucas never fully explained why it was that Anakin chose these darker colors,
but visually it was just meant to foreshadow what was going to be coming for him,
like you all know that he's turning into Darth Vader,
so wouldn't it make sense that he'd have some darker tendencies that would show themselves
in the way he dressed and the things that he did, the way he acted.
But I think part of the reason people are so upset about Kylo Ren,
in addition to him being written in a really beta way,
is the fact that he doesn't seem to have a personality of his own.
He's just trying to co-opt Darth Vader's personality, like he's this young teenager who's lost his way,
so he sees this iconic figure that he finds out that he's related to, so he's like,
"Oh my god, I'm going to be just like that. I'm going to do exactly what he did."
So you never really find out who Ben Solo was.
You only know who the faux Anakin Skywalker/Darth Vader is, walking around in this makeshift mask.
But if you're not a huge fan of the character,
the cool thing is is that Adam Driver did say that they would explore some of his humanity,
so you'd find a little bit about what's going on in his head during Episode IIX.
Even though most of the focus has now shifted off of him onto Luke Skywalker,
because people are like, 'what is going on with this crazy person?"
'"The Jedi need to end"? That is the craziest thing that has ever come out of your mouth.'
But, Luke Skywalker as Rey's father -- so that was one of the biggest theories,
So we've got to talk about Rey's parents.
That's like the next big thing that they kind of unofficially revealed,
or at least cut a bunch of theories out,
So a bunch of you messaged me after they dropped the trailer, they did the big panel,
asking about these two things, like, 'hey, are they actually confirming this?'
So there was a later interview that Daisy Ridley did that I'll play in a second.
This was Josh Gad making jokes onstage about trying to get them to reveal who Rey's parents were.
"Rey Skywalker?" "Rey Kenobi?"
Are you and Luke related by blood?
No to that one, okay.
Are you a Skywalker?
Is your name Rey Skywalker?
Is your name Rey Kenobi?
That's a popular answer, clearly.
Who doesn't know their own last name?
So the important thing to remember about that is that Star Wars secrecy is so hardcore
that all of that is carefully choreographed,
they tell him what he's allowed to make jokes about before they go out there,
and I don't think they'd let him kae that joke if there was even a small chance
that Rey was either a Kenobi or a Skywalker.
Now the interview that Daisy Ridley did provides some even better evidence,
so I'm going to play this clip here, and then I'll explain what that means.
So how is Rey's relationship in this movie different than Luke's relationship with, say, Yoda or Obi-Wan?
Um, well, Rey is not a teacher.
Yoda and Obi-Wan are very much, like, guiding figures in Luke's life
and, um, Rey, I think, obviously he doesn't even know who she is when she turns up,
like, with this frickin' lightsaber that he's not seen in however long
so that in itself is a big difference, and then as things go on, I think there's an expectation,
there's always been an expectation on Luke as to his potential and what he can do or what he should do,
much like with Rey, so in that sense they're kind of similar, but obviously the dynamic has changed
because she's expecting something from him this time,
and it remains to be seen, whether, you know, how he reacts to that.
So I know it sounds like she's making a couple off-handed remarks
about the initial meeting with Luke Skywalker
He's never seen her before, he has no idea, "Who are you?"
That does not sound like something that a father who's being reunited with his child would say at all.
"Who are you? I've never seen you before."
So that also means that she probably wasn't a student at his Jedi academy.
The way they're presenting Luke Skywalker is that he was kind of a failure
when everybody had these big hopes for him after the Empire fell
but that's some pretty damning evidence, if he doesn't know who she is,
and he has that crazy force connection to his sister Leia, he would know if she had another child with Han Solo,
and she were a Solo, so she'd still be part Skywalker in that case.
But now it just sounds like there's much more evidence that she is a completely new character
that we've never met before.
That doesn't mean that she's not related to someone in the Star Wars universe, it just implies that she's not
related to the people that you would think that she would be related to.
So the big thing now that she has in common with the Snoke character is that they both seem like
brand new characters that you've never met before in the Star Wars universe.
And even though they keep reiterating that this is very much a story about the Skywalker family,
the Skywalker part of that story looks like it's coming through the Ben Solo character
So I know everybody really wanted Rey to be part of the Skywalker family, or even Obi-Wan,
so you have this really nice unbroken line of Skywalker lineage from Anakin Skywalker,
but most of that is flowing through the Ben Solo character,
and Rey, just like the MacGuffin, the Journal of the Whills in the trailer, is representative of
the new thing that they're bringing in, the new way they're headed.
So you have this idea of just recycling old content, recylcing old Darth Vader in Ben Solo.
We need something new, something fresh.
So practically, during the plot of the movie, as well as metaphorically in the Star Wars expanded universe,
like them actually making these movies, they need to inject fresh things,
So you have the Journal of the Whills helping contextualize Star Wars mythology
within the story,
and then you have the Rey character, someone new to take that path.
This was all part of Mark Hamill talking a lot about how it's not Luke's story anymore,
and then Kathleen Kennedy jumped out and was like, "But Luke is still a very important part of this."
Like she didn't want him to downplay Luke's importance in the story
So the Skywalkers are still a very big part of the direction that the Star Wars galaxy is headed
But you'll probably see, once they start announcing more spinoff movies,
and whatever trilogy is going to come next after Episode IX,
is that they'll start moving past the idea of the lineage of Darth Vader
But let me know, just based on Daisy Ridley's comments and Luke Skywalker not knowing who she is,
who do you think her parents are?
Are they completely new characters, which is what it seems like they're implying,
or do you think it's somebody else inside the Star Wars universe?
So I know you're all wondering when we're going to see new footage,
the next big Star Wars day is May the 4th, Star Wars Day, may the Fourth be with you.
they will definitely be promoting Star Wars on that day, but there hasn't been any confirmation of new footage
I'm not expecting a new trailer.
So if they do drop new video content, it's more likely that it would be behind the scenes stuff
which is still very revealing, we learned a whole bunch of stuff from The Force Awakens behind the scenes reel
and D23 is happening later this summer, like the week or two before Comic Con happens,
and they'll probably be presenting more Star Wars footage.
They usually don't release that D23 footage to the public, but during the last D23 during a Star Wars year,
they did air Force Awakens content, so I'm expecting them to do the same thing for Last Jedi.
And really like the last big thing is Episode IX.
If you've been reading about what's going on with them developing the project,
Colin Trevorrow, who did Jurassic World, is directing the movie
they're working on a different treatment, Rian Johnson was originally writing a version of the script,
but they said that he's not involved with that anymore, he's just doing Episode IIX
And Kathleen Kennedy just reiterated that they're not going to have some crazy trick
to try to work Leia into Episode IX.
So they're going to do whatever they can to honor her character, and not completely upset everyone
that would just freak out if they saw CG Leia in Episode IX, so don't worry about that.
But leave all your requests for new Star Wars videos in the comments below
Because next week is going to be Star Wars Day, there'll be some extra Star Wars stuff posting
But there's some new Avengers Infinity War that I want to post, there's new American Gods,
and a whole bunch more comic book stuff.
So while you wait for that, you can click here to re-watch that Star Wars trailer,
and you can click here for my non-spoilery Guardians of the Galaxy II review.
Thank you so much for watching, let's high five, I'll see you guys tonight.